Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
A caustic is a beautiful phenomenon in nature
where curved surfaces reflect or refract light,
thereby concentrating it to a relatively small
area.
If it's not your favorite visual phenomenon
in nature yet, which is almost impossible,
then you absolutely have to watch this episode.
If it is, all the better because you're gonna
love what's coming up now!
Imagine that we have a photorealistic
rendering program that simulates the path
of light rays in a scene that we put together,
and creates beautiful imagery of our caustics.
However, since we, humans are pretty bad at
estimating how exactly caustics should look
like, one can manipulate them to be more in
line with their artistic vision.
Previously, we had an episode on a technique
which made it possible to pull the caustic
patterns to be more visible, but this paper
offers a much more sophisticated toolset to
torment these caustic patterns to our liking.
We can specify a target pattern that we would
like to see, and obtain a blend between what
would normally happen in physics and what
we imagined to appear there.
It also supports animated sequences.
Artists who use these tools are just as skilled
in their trade as the scientists who created
this algorithm, so I can only imagine the
miracles they will create with such a technique.
If you are interested in diving into photorealistic
rendering, material modeling and all that
cool stuff, there are completely free and
open source tools out there like Blender that
you can use. If you would like to get started,
check out CynicatPro's YouTube channel that
has tons of really great material. Here is
a quick teaser of his channel.
Thanks! There is a link to his channel in
the description box, make sure to check it
out and subscribe if you like what you see
there.
I just realized that the year has barely started
and it is already lavishing in beautiful papers.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!